seul notre parti conservateur reconnaît
la gravité de la menace du terrorisme
djihadiste mondiale représente pour
notre fierté
à l'instar de l'australie stephen harper
souhaite criminaliser les voyages des
canadiens dans des zones du monde
reconnu pour être des foyers de
terroristes et de djihadistes les
régions de l'irak et de la syrie où le
groupe etat islamique est actif
le chef conservateur a donné très peu de
détails hier mais pourquoi une telle
proposition surtout comment
pourrait-elle être appliquée
j'en parle avec juste hamas il est
professeur de science politique à l'uqam
en somme ce massif au soir d'abord
pourquoi maintenant cette volonté de
criminaliser les voyages de certains
canadiens dans certaines régions du
monde
c'est assez étonnant parce qu'il ya
quelques mois seulement le gouvernement
canadien du parti conservateur a adopté
une série de mesures la loi ces 51 dans
le cadre de son grand programme vaste
programme antiterroriste
on n'a pas jugé bon d'inclure une telle
disposition d'interdiction de vol ou de
présence dans certaines régions dans le
monde et donc on peut douter du fait de
l'imminence ou la laine de la nécessité
immédiat d'avoir une telle mesure
ajoutée soufflé au code criminel
canadien parce qu'on a élargi énormément
les pouvoirs des services de
renseignement c'est présentement
possible de révoquer il passe pas ou de
tout simplement refusé de donner le
passeport canadien qui veut aller dans
telle région
donc on a les moyens si on veut de
stopper des gens qui voudraient ou qui
serait aller vite et contre eux on a
beaucoup de moyens ici ce serait une
mesure supplémentaire dont l'objectif
est peut être louable on veut empêcher
que les canadiens participent aux
actions terroristes
mais ici la stratégie est très dissuasif
très coercitives en est on vise ici des
gens qui sont déjà radicalisé au canada
qui se déplace dans cette région et le
petit nombre qui décide de revenir
ensuite au canada et pour commettre des
actions terroristes encore par de très
peu de personnes par une stratégie plus
efficace serait dans la prévention de la
radicalisation ou la déradicalisation au
canada et sans y apporter dans les
mesures adoptées ou proposée par le
parti conservateur
donc s'il n'y a pas de nécessité ce
serait le contexte électoral qui
expliquerait une telle
c'est sûr que le contexte électoral
c'est une des grandes différences entre
mai dernier c'est à dire que on adopte
une mesure on juge pas bon d'inclure
cette disposition là et là soudainement
le premier ministre nous dit c'est
nécessaire à la sécurité des canadiens
alors ça rentre dans le discours aux
petits partis conservateurs qui tente de
faire de la sécurité un enjeu important
de ces élections si en dix ans deux
choses d'abord que nous vivons dans un
monde très dangereux et d'autre part que
seul le parti conservateur est en mesure
d'assurer la sécurité des canadiens
or les deux des formations des deux
affirmations méritent d'être nuancés
sofialys est d'ailleurs rare qu'un enjeu
de politique étrangère comme ça prennent
beaucoup de place dans une campagne
électorale
j'étais très rare n'y a pas de précédent
à court terme que de mémoire qu'on peut
se rappeler à cet effet bon dans les
faits ce que ça serait concrètement
applicables ce genre d'une politique
c'est assez difficile parce qu'il
faudrait que les services de
renseignement prouve que vous êtes allé
dans la ville spécifiquement désignée
comme étant interdits d'accès par le
gouvernement canadien
et là ça va impliquer les services de
renseignement sache où est ce que vous
êtes allé où vous exige à vous de
prouver que vous êtes allé dans cette
région là à des fins légitimes donc en
renversant le fardeau de la preuve et le
sac si très compliqué dans la raison des
droits évidemment de légitime un voyage
dans le monde par les canadiens donc ça
a été ça a été voté en australie et là
on voit qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
controverses sur tours justement de la
présomption d'innocence se soucier des
australiens donc se questionne à savoir
ce qu'on est allé trop loin parce qu'on
renverse le fardeau de la preuve vous
devez prouver votre innocence plutôt que
le gouvernement il doit prouver que vous
avez été dans cette région pour des
actions terroristes et là c'est très
difficile d'autant plus que monsieur
harper a ajouté une nuance est à dire
que ça ne concernerait que les canadiens
qui veulent lutter pour le groupe armé
et en islamique
or c'est très difficile parce qu'il ya
des canadiens qui se déplacent pour
ludique également contre le groupe etat
islamique qui lui seraient exemptés donc
il faudrait que le gouvernement canadien
réussissent à prouver vos intentions il
y avait qui vous avez lutté en syrie par
exemple
or cette guerre civile beaucoup de
faction c'est extrêmement complexe à
mettre en oeuvre
il est difficile d'identifier les gens
qui s'en vont directement en série ou en
irak parce que les gens en général ne
passe pas ils ne vont pas directement là
bas ils passent par la turquie
exactement c'est vraiment la turquie qui
est la plaque tournante là où les
occidentaux voyage pour ensuite se
rendre en syrie se déplacer à pied ou
dons
moyens en irak et en syrie et donc sa
cause la porte quand même voilà parce
que beaucoup de canadiens qui voyagent
en turquie à défendre tout à fait
légitime de tourisme et donc est ce que
pourraient être visés par cette loi là
on n'en sait rien parce que le me
surprennent n'a pas précisé sa pensée à
cet égard alors on attendra d'autres
détails merci beaucoup mais ce mois ci
je vous en prie